jusqu'ici ils ne s'étaient croisés que
furtivement aux nations unies donald
trump ne prêtera pas attention à la
jeune militant mais il a regardé avec
envie la personnalité de l'année du
times au point que son équipe de
campagne a détourné la une ce mardi ils
étaient de nouveau réunis au même
endroit
la riche station de ski de davos en
suisse pour le forum économique mondial
il dit croire dur comme fer à
l'environnement son discours lui met
plutôt l'accent sur la prospérité
économique
pendant que l'une prône l'arrêt des
investissements dans les énergies
fossiles et me dit en face au fils
d'ennis l'autre vente les réserves
d'énergie américain et ajoute nous ne
laisserons pas les radicaux-socialistes
détruire notre économie et notre pays
aucun plan économique ou politique sans
baisse radicale des émissions polluantes
est utile rétorque que l'activité en
faire car le monde est en feu mais tout
ça ce ne sont que des prophéties pour
donald trump dom et nous n'avons pas
besoin de ces prophètes de malheur le
prix nobel d'économie joseph stiglitz
n'entre à priori ni dans la catégorie
des prophètes de malheur ni des radicaux
socialistes et il juge son président
déconnecté des réalités climatiques et
économiques
le forum de davos se tient jusqu'à
vendredi au coeur des alpes suisses
ici mathieu prost radio canada